yo guys what's up everybody its prestige
again and today we're playing them
Quarter Quell which is like hunger games
but bit different since different map
style different little effects in the
game so we 10-second still starts and
this is the small wall beauty of like
six people so hopefully this is gonna be
a really really quick game oh that was a
terrible start terrible start okay this
is good good all right I'm gonna when I
get over there Oh everyone's beating me
everybody's beating me okay let's see
where what chest they go to all right no
one with this chest get all right I got
some good armor good armor and I'm
assuming all the other chest doesn't
move it yep all right or go or if you
don't know The Hunger Games number to
the second movie I'm in some way it's
bad the second movie is a split up like
a clock and each section of the map over
the area has like plate things so that's
what's going to happen in this one so
the little different than normal in
games where is just maps and you just
find stuff to kill each other excuse me
excuse me so we're gonna go around
looking for chest so hoping we don't get
stuck in the part of the map that's all
play eat and we have a little bit of
time 10 seconds until we find out if
we're in that plate part the plagues can
range from a lot of stuff like blood
mist to explosive blocks falling on you
but my double Honda all right um so I'm
not seeing any message that tells me I'm
in the bad it's good there's only guy
just one of those 16 feet maybe not
anyway just nice I don't need any shoes
and you know that's person jack is a
full iron guy i'm not gonna go near them
and man this map i'm recording let's get
all the land it's quite annoying say did
he see me doesn't look like he's awful
gonna hope he didn't see me oh if i
tribute so somebody died is somebody
left I really need a weapon because is
it for they start that match just
instantaneously deathmatch the hilarious
oh come on walking weapon nope I'm close
to being it 1000 that's why I'm talking
about all right then
just dance to any pants I did a poo
pants what I thought I got pants
confused let's put on all my goods then
oh I did put odd i already put on my
pants as i can see all right then we
need oh okay i'm getting high cpu usage
from crap sorry about that so that's not
a good thing since then the recording
will go down or so we can we can
definitely fight some people we're
pretty buff the only piece of armor
we're missing is leggings for full iron
hopefully we can run around maybe find
an iron ingot and go crap I get iron
sword so we can write these nubs there's
like my fourth or so game of known solo
added up probably do a lot better if I
went with a partner and I'm I if you
guys are looking this loving this mini
games ooh there's a person there was
totally person here's our loving this
mini games and I will definitely do more
and with other people because that'd be
great alright so I'm going to eat some
check there nope there's so many
feathers gosh I'm going to eat it's
actually because the chicken will
restore me pull oh so this is where
somebody died oh that is so the other
person who saw I'm pretty sure I saw him
in full irons that's why he threw away
these a chain leggings chin leggings are
second-best too many players in the hub
nope okay I don't know where I the other
person I saw when if they don't have an
if they have an iron store I'll probably
lose but if they don't I can I
definitely have a chance of beating that
even though they better armor than me
what was that what I'm talking about
nope uh-uh click the food so yeah and
other games I played I got in like four
of the twelve I think 12 plagues and
this game apparently got none it's
probably gonna jinx mean I'm gonna get
so when you get sent only three tributes
o yep I guess we're doing the death
match okay well I guess we won't have to
worry about the plagues all right quick
game good game I'm going to head over to
Center see what steep and
is there probably checking Chester too
just in case we can get that one iron
ingot that we need you've done it sticks
out of a boat like that bow yeah these
are all gonna be very second till death
match anybody want to fight me in the
center come on come on your knobs let's
go let's go come on come on all right so
that man wants to fight me in the center
try run away from him yeah it's run away
probably has a boat me to shoot me ready
to the death knight sharks I'm gonna get
in water you're just gonna keep shooting
you though I'm gonna hit me out of the
map yeah oh oh actually oh oh I
shouldn't have let him craft is that
that's definitely a dime is that a
diamond sword oh gosh he hit me ok
alright well he he is um closer to me
that's good that's good so when is it
does so okay okay I'm gonna run to that
guy since he seems less straight up boo
who dodged dodged all right yea though
why does that man get a diamond sword
see really seriously that man gets damn
sword are you kidding me um oh there's a
giant oh one of those sorts of things
okay we're gonna have to help this guy
let me fight in are you kidding me okay
well I'm going at this then I don't k
well that's good uh oh here's the heel
or avenge my come on come on alright
well he killed me think baka that's of
annoys me alright but um okay he killed
Ana he had a diamond sword and he had
the same armors me yeah the surface
cleaning up you will be returned to love
it art the other say Marvins me so I
don't really care too much about losing
so hope you guys have enjoyed this if
you did make sure you let me know so I
will do more this thing and if you
didn't let me know so i won't do more
the thing but that's about it and i
think i'll see you guys later peace
No
the sky